This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the 4th century, a young man named Aurelius Augustinus found himself in a struggle with himself. He was born in what is today Algeria, but at that time was part of the Roman Empire. Aurelius found himself torn between the dictates of his faith and the impulses of his own body. of his faith and the impulses of his own body. I was bound down by this disease of the flesh, he wrote. Its deadly pleasures were a chain that I dragged along with me. Aurelius was infatuated with his lover. He felt his attraction to her was purely physical, and this felt wrong to him.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在公元4世纪，一个名叫奥勒留·奥古斯丁的年轻人发现自己陷入了内心挣扎。他出生于今天的阿尔及利亚，但当时那是罗马帝国的一部分。奥勒留发现自己在信仰的清规戒律和身体的冲动之间左右为难。他写道：“我被肉体的这种疾病所束缚。它致命的快乐就像我拖着的一条铁链。”奥勒留迷恋上了他的情人。他觉得自己对她的吸引力纯粹是生理上的，这让他觉得不对劲。
Aurelius happened to be one of the most prolific writers of his time, so we have a detailed picture of his mind from his various books and writings. At one point he said, Aurelius, whom devout Catholics know today as St. Augustine, is said to have prayed for divine assistance to battle his cravings. But his appeal to God revealed his own divided self. Lord, give me chastity and continence, he prayed. Only not yet. For thousands of years, human beings have tried different techniques to get control over their desires and cravings.
奥勒留恰好是他那个时代最多产的作家之一，因此通过他的各种书籍和著作，我们能对其内心世界有一个详细的了解。他曾一度表示……虔诚的天主教徒今天尊称他为圣奥古斯丁，据说奥勒留曾祈求神灵的协助来对抗他的欲望。但他对上帝的呼求暴露了他分裂的内心。他祈祷道：“主啊，请赐予我纯洁和节制，但现在还不要。”几千年来，人类尝试了各种技术来控制自己的欲望和渴求。
These battles have made their way into myths and legends. In the Odyssey, the famous epic by the Greek poet Homer, the warrior Odysseus orders his men to bind him to the mast of his own ship, so he cannot succumb to the temptations of the beautiful, human-like creatures known as the sirens. In modern times, the diet industry has offered thousands of books and videos to help people get control over their food cravings. The pharmaceutical industry has come up with drugs that suppress appetite. Addiction researchers and treatment centers all over the world
这些抗争已经融入了神话和传说中。在希腊诗人荷马的著名史诗《奥德赛》中，勇士奥德修斯命令他的手下将他绑在自己船的桅杆上，这样他就不会向塞壬——那些美丽如人形的生物——的诱惑屈服。在现代，减肥行业提供了数千本书籍和视频，帮助人们控制对食物的渴望。制药行业也推出了抑制食欲的药物。全世界的成瘾研究人员和治疗中心
help people battle cravings for alcohol, drugs, and sex. Our long battle with ourselves is testament to the deep powers of human desire. Over and over, as you look down history, people have reported that they felt powerless and helpless in the face of their cravings. This week on Hidden Brain, the science of cravings and provocative ideas to get a hold
都在帮助人们对抗对酒精、毒品和性瘾的渴望。我们与自我的长期抗争证明了人类欲望的深层力量。纵观历史，人们一次又一次地报告说，面对自己的渴望时，他们感到无能为力、无可奈何。本周的“隐藏的大脑”将探讨关于渴望的科学，以及控制它们的挑衅性观点。从我们出生那天起，我们的心灵就自带一种对事物产生渴望的驱动力。我们本能地寻求维持生命和安全的源泉。随着年龄的增长，我们的欲望变得复杂。几个世纪以来，人类发现了许多能够改变我们感受的物质。酒精、香烟和毒品的普及证明了我们对寻求兴奋、放松和解脱的持久能力。在布朗大学，精神病学家贾德·布鲁尔研究着渴望的科学、我们通常如何应对渴望，以及我们应该如何应对渴望。
of them. From the time we are newborns, our minds come with a built-in drive to crave things. We instinctively seek out sources of sustenance and safety. As we grow older, our desires grow complex. Over centuries, humans have discovered many substances that change the way we feel. The popularity of alcohol, cigarettes, and drugs are testament to our enduring capacity to seek out exhilaration, relaxation, and relief. At Brown University, psychiatrist Judson Brewer studies the science of cravings, how we usually respond to them, and how we should respond to them.
贾德·布鲁尔，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢邀请我来。贾德，我想带你回到你的高中时代。据我所能了解，你曾是一名严肃的运动员，但每隔一段时间，你就会对冰淇淋产生强烈的渴望。跟我讲讲那件事。在高中时，我有着非常严格的饮食习惯，
Jud Brewer, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Judd, I want to take you back to your days in high school. I understand you were a serious athlete, but every once in a while, you would be consumed with a craving for ice cream. Tell me about that. In high school, I had a very strict diet,
因为我试图掌控我能控制的一切来提高我的运动表现，我需要所有能得到的帮助。所以你知道的，就是不吃糖、不吃精制食品、不吃甜食、不吃糖果、不吃快餐、不吃垃圾食品，当然更不吃冰淇淋。而在休赛期，你知道的，
because I was trying to dial in everything that I had control over to try to improve my athletic performance and I needed all the help I could get. So I, you know, it was no sugar, no refined foods, no sweets, no candy, no fast food, no junk food, and certainly no ice cream. And when I was off season, you know,
我看到别人吃冰淇淋，就会被这种渴望击中。我就想，哦，那个看起来太棒了。我记得自己曾独自吃掉将近半桶，大概半加仑的冰淇淋，你知道的，就在一次吃完的时候。通常我会自己一个人做这事，但我当时就觉得，哦，我只是，你知道的，
I would see people eating ice cream and I would just be struck with this craving. I was like, oh, that looks so good. And I remember eating close to half a tub, like half a gallon of ice cream, you know, in single settings. Generally I would do this by myself, but I was like, oh, I just, you know,
我非得吃它不可。当贾德年纪更大一些时，他嗜甜如命的渴望从冰淇淋转向了软糖虫。他简直无法满足于那些由明胶、玉米糖浆和调味剂制成的多色条状糖果。它们起作用的方式是，正如某人所说，它们的味道就像是让你“还想再吃”。这意味着它们不一定很好吃，但它们会在你嘴里让你甚至在你还没嚼完嘴里那颗的时候，就想要吃下一颗。而这几颗变成了很多颗，最后变成了整整一袋，
I just had to get it in. When Judd was older, his sweet tooth cravings took a turn from ice cream to gummy worms. He simply could not get enough of those multicolored strips of candy made of gelatin, corn syrup, and flavorings. The way they work is I think they're designed, as somebody put it, to taste like more. Meaning they're not necessarily gonna taste good, but they're gonna be in your mouth making you want that next one before you even finish chewing the one that you're eating. And that few turned into many turned into the whole bag,
几乎每一次都是这样。而且通常是在深夜，我刚吃了很多东西，所以其实并不饿。突然间我就会听到它们在召唤。那将是软糖虫的塞壬之歌，它们会在橱柜里呼唤我，对我说，你知道的，吃我，吃我，来吧，来吧。你知道吗？
virtually every time. And it was generally late at night, plenty of food that I'd just eaten, so I wasn't hungry. And suddenly I'd hear them calling. It would be that siren song of the gummy worms, where they'd be in the cabinet calling to me, saying, you know, eat me, eat me, come, come. You know?
我想我当时还不是奥德修斯，没有把自己绑在桅杆上来阻止自己吃它们，或者让别人替我这么做。基本上就是，它们呼唤，我就会前往。所以作为一名精神病学家，贾德，你在专业上与那些在管理渴望方面遇到困难的人共事。你称之为杰姬的一位患者多年来一直在与她的饮食习惯作斗争。
And I guess I wasn't quite a disius where I was lashing myself to the masts to keep myself from eating them or having somebody do that for me. It was basically, they would call and I would come. So as a psychiatrist, Judd, you work in a professional capacity with people who have trouble managing their cravings. One patient whom you call Jackie struggled for years with her eating
把我们带回到她童年的开始。作为儿童和青少年，她与食物的关系是怎样的？嗯，杰姬小时候曾有过这种想法，她觉得自己需要看起来更像格温妮丝·帕特罗，但她有着摇滚巨星粉妈（Pink）的体型，后者相当健硕，我得说。这就是我如何形容她的体型。所以她会尝试一切可能的方法来迎合这种骨感美的社会规范，并为此挣扎了很长时间，
habits. Take us back to the start of her childhood. What was her relationship to food like as a child and as an adolescent? Well, Jackie back as a kid had this idea that she needed to look more like Gwyneth Paltrow, but she had the build of the rock star Pink, who is pretty muscular, I have to say. That's how I would describe her physique. And so she would try everything that she could to meet this societal norm of what skinny looked like and really struggled for a long time
甚至到了节食的地步。在某个时候，她发现了香烟，并发现这可以成为抑制食欲的一种方法。她还和一个朋友陷入了一种用吃东西来抚慰情绪的模式。她学会了因为难过而吃东西。然后最终陷入了严重节食，接着在无法坚持那种节食时又暴饮暴食的循环中。
to the point where she would restrict eating. At some point she discovered cigarettes and found that that could be a way to curb her appetite. She also fell into this pattern with a friend of eating to soothe her emotions. She would learn to eat because she was sad. And then eventually just got into this cycle of severe restriction and then binging
当杰姬进入成年期后，她开始根据自己为自己设定的一长串规则来试图限制饮食。你说她经常觉得自己像是被判处了“食物监狱”的监禁。是的，她并不是第一个这样描述的人。
when she couldn't stick with that restrictive diet. As Jackie entered adulthood, she began to try to restrict her eating in accordance with a long list of rules that she had set for herself. You say that she often felt like she had been sentenced to food jail. Yes, and she's not the first person to describe this.
我认为这是一个非常普遍的现象，她会设定所有的食物规则，然后当她违反规则时，她就会把自己关进监狱，然后因为无法抗拒冲动而狠狠地自责。她觉得自己身上出了什么问题，具有讽刺意味的是，她会因为自己无法控制的事情而把自己关进监狱。
I think it's a very common thing where she would set all these food rules and then she would put herself in jail for violating the rules and then beat herself up for not being able to resist the urges. She felt like there was something wrong with her and ironically, she would put herself in jail for something that she couldn't control.
因此，在这种非常严格的制度下生活，她甚至为自己对某些食物不可抗拒的渴望想出了一个名字。我听说她甚至将这些渴望拟人化了。杰姬描述了她所谓的“渴望怪兽”，那里有一个巨大的、隐约可见的、潜伏着的、强大的、可怕的怪兽，它基本上会说：吃。而且它通常可以从一个低语开始，比如，哦，你知道的，你喜欢这个，你想要这个。
So living under this very restrictive regime, she even came up with her own name for the irresistible desire to eat certain foods. I understand she even personified these cravings. Jackie described what she called the craving monster, where there was this big, looming, lurking, powerful, scary monster that would just basically say, eat. And it could often start as a whisper, like, oh, you know, you like this, you want this.
然后，如果她忽略它或不听它的，声音就会变大。比如，反正你也要这么做，不如现在就做吧。然后最后就像是在嘲弄她，怂恿她，甚至对她大喊大叫。杰姬会试图忽视渴望怪兽。然后她会试图与它搏斗。但她越是与之抗争，它似乎就变得越强大。这就像那些科幻电影一样，你杀了一个怪兽，
And then if she ignored it or didn't listen to it, it would get louder. Like, well, you're going to do this anyway, so you might as well do it now. And then eventually just like taunting her and then egging her on and then even yelling at her. Jackie would try to ignore the craving monster. Then she would try to fight it. But the more she battled it, the stronger it seemed to become. It was like one of those sci-fi movies where you kill a monster only
却看到它重新组装并再次复活。她能消灭它多少次？你知道的，觉得自己无法取胜，她就会妥协，于是她会打电话给中餐馆，点她所说的“令人作呕的大量碳水化合物”，比如炸土豆、米饭、咖喱河粉。然后，你知道的，有趣的是，她说当这些不复存在时有一种巨大的解脱感，尽管你觉得自己伤痕累累、腹胀如牛。但她形容说，至少你不用再和那个怪兽搏斗了。
to see it reassemble itself and rise up again. How many times could she slay it? You know, feeling like there was no way to win, she'd relent and so she'd dial her Chinese restaurant in order as she put it, disgustingly vast amounts of carbs, so fried potatoes and rice and rice noodles with curry dishes. And then, you know, interestingly, she said that there's this huge relief that it's not there anymore, even though you feel all battered and bloated. But she described it, at least you're not fighting that monster anymore.
所以引人注目的是，这个过程，你知道的，抵制诱惑又抵制诱惑，然后以一种戏剧性的方式向其屈服，这不仅在我们自己的生活中非常熟悉，而且在书本、电视剧和电影中上演的场景中也非常熟悉。在电影《浓情巧克力》中，一个女人和她的女儿搬到一个法国小村庄开了一家巧克力店，
So what's striking is that this sequence, you know, holding out and holding out against temptation and then giving into it in spectacular fashion, this is so familiar, not only from our own lives, but from scenes played out in books and in TV shows and in movies. In the movie Chocolat, a woman and her daughter move to a small French village and open a chocolate shop,
但麻烦很快接踵而至。据我所知你是这部电影的粉丝。那是什么样的麻烦，贾德？哦，我很喜欢这部电影。它是关于这个小巧、古雅的法国小镇的，那里非常干净、井井有条且虔诚。而这个女人乘着北风或别的什么刮进城里，她穿着这件红斗篷，
but complications quickly ensue. I understand that you're a fan of this movie. What kind of complications, Judd? Oh, I love this movie. It's about this small, quaint French town that's very clean and orderly and pious. And this woman blows in on the North wind or something and she's wearing this red cape,
有点象征着魔鬼。而这确实是关于诱惑的。她开了一家巧克力店，然后开始制作这些镇上谁也无法抗拒的惊艳巧克力。所以镇长认为自己是最虔诚的公民、道德的楷模，当然，这正值大斋期。
kind of signifying the devil. And this is really, this is about temptations. And she sets up this chocolate shop and then starts making these amazing chocolates that nobody in the town can resist. And so the mayor of the town who considers himself to be the most pious and the model citizen, this is during Lent, of course.
所以我想他在大斋期放弃了甜食。因此，在大斋期期间，他喝柠檬水作为他的，你知道的。但随着时间的推移，这种诱惑在整部电影中越来越强烈。我想播放这部电影的一个简短片段，因为我认为这象征着我们思考对抗欲望的最佳方式的方式。在这个片段中，镇长在教堂里跪下，恳求摆脱他长期被否认的欲望。
And so I think he's giving up sweets for Lent. And so he drinks like lemon water as his you know, throughout the course of Lent. But over time, this temptation builds up more and more and more throughout the movie. I want to play a brief clip from this film, because I think this is emblematic of the way we've come to think about the best way to battle our desires. In this clip, the mayor drops to his knees in church and pleads for relief from his long
我所有的努力都白费了。我甘愿受苦。我禁食。我已经好几周几乎没吃东西了。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我的痛苦算不了什么。只是我感觉太迷茫了。
denied desires. All my efforts have been for nothing. I have suffered willingly. I've fasted. I've hardly eaten for weeks now. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. my suffering is nothing. It's just I feel so lost.
我不知道该怎么办。告诉我该怎么办。他去了，我不想剧透任何还没看过这部电影的人，但我还是得说，这是一个剧透警告。电影结尾，他去砸毁那家巧克力店。所以他 literalmente 冲进巧克力店
I don't know what to do. Tell me what to do. He goes, and I don't want to ruin the movie for anybody that hasn't seen it, but I'm gonna go ahead and, you know, it's a spoiler alert. End of the movie, he goes in to destroy the chocolate shop. So he literally busts into the chocolate shop
开始破坏这个地方。所以他在前窗摆满了所有这些漂亮的巧克力，然后他走进去开始，你知道的，践踏它们，开始把它们撕裂、打碎，你知道的，摧毁它们。而在某个时刻，一小滴巧克力牛轧糖或糖浆落进他嘴里。
and starts destroying the place. So he has all these beautiful chocolates set up in the front window, and he goes in there and he just starts, you know, treading them, starts tearing them apart, breaking them, you know, destroying them. And at one point, a little drip of like chocolate nougat or syrup lands in his mouth.
这就好像是他的氪石。突然间他就像是，哦，我不能再这样了。然后他开始狂吃巧克力。他因为巧克力狂热而昏倒，浑身沾满了巧克力。就好像，哦不。这是一个我们许多人都能感同身受的故事。我们用巨大的努力和自律守住对渴望的底线，直到我们再也无法坚持。当我们回来时，为什么自我控制经常让我们失败，以及对更好方法的惊鸿一瞥？你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
And it's like his kryptonite. And suddenly he's like, oh, I can't do this anymore. And he just starts gorging himself on chocolate. And he passes out from his chocolate frenzy just covered in chocolate. It's like, oh no. It's a story that many of us can relate to. With great effort and self-discipline, we hold the line on our cravings until we cannot. on our cravings until we cannot. When we come back, why self-control often fails us and a glimpse into a better approach? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。纵观人类历史，进步的故事一直是关于获得对外部世界的控制。汹涌的河流被筑起大坝，森林大火变成了可控的烧除，风浪被转化为电能。我们在科学和技术上取得的许多成功促使我们相信我们控制能力是无止境的，这并不令人意外。但是，当我们试图控制最难驾驭的力量时，这种方法效果如何？我们自己的心灵。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Throughout human history, the story of progress has been about gaining control over the external world. Raging rivers have been dammed, forest fires have become controlled burns, the wind and the waves have been turned into electricity. It is not surprising that our many successes in science and technology have prompted us to believe that our capacity for control is endless. But how does this approach work when we try to control that most unruly of forces? Our own minds.
如果我们能让强大的河流臣服，如果我们能为地震做计划和准备，如果我们能分裂原子并控制其中可怕的力量，我们肯定会认为自己应该能够控制自己的欲望、冲动和渴望。当贾德·布鲁尔在医学院时，他的老师教导他，克服渴望的方法很简单。毒品？酒精？暴饮暴食？
If we can bring mighty rivers to heel, if we can plan and prepare for earthquakes, if we can split atoms and control the terrible power they contain, surely we think we should be able to control our own desires, urges and cravings. When Judd Brewer was in medical school, his teachers taught him that the way to overcome cravings was straightforward. Drugs? Alcohol? Overeating?
没问题。只要说不。他们基本上说，你知道的，这里有一个公式，摄入的热量，消耗的热量。他们说得好像这是一个牛顿物理学的事实。你知道的，就像是，这就是规律。这是真的，而且每次都管用。他们没有告诉我的是，这在临床实践中实际上并不是这样运作的。
No problem. Just say no. They basically said, you know, there's this formula, calories in, calories out. And they stated it like it was a fact of Newtonian physics. You know, it was like, this is the law. And this is true. and it works every time. What they didn't tell me was, that's not actually how it works in clinical practice.
这个公式是真的，我想学生们可能还在学它，但这不是它在现实生活中真正起作用的方式。例如，戒烟是最难戒除的瘾头之一，有这五个循证的“A”（询问、建议、评估、协助、安排）。所以你要询问，你要建议，你要评估，你要协助，你要安排。但这个想法只是检查是否有人在这个时候准备好戒烟。
The formula is true, I think students probably still learn it, but that's not how it actually works in real life. For smoking cessation, for example, which is one of the hardest addictions to quit, there are these evidence-based five A's. So you ask, you advise, you assess, you assist, and you arrange. But the idea is just check to see if somebody's ready to quit at this time.
向他们发表非常强烈的声明，说明吸烟对他们真的很不好，他们其实都已经知道了。然后说，好吧，让我们帮你戒烟。而咨询部分主要集中在意志力上，咬紧牙关戒掉就行。所以在位于康涅狄格州西黑文的退伍军人管理局医院你的第一份工作时，
Give them a very strong statement that smoking's really bad for them, which they all already know. And then say, okay, let's help you quit. And the counseling piece was mostly focused on willpower, just grit your teeth and quit. So at one of your first jobs at the Veterans Administration Hospital in West Haven, Connecticut,
你的许多病人都是经历过战斗的士兵。他们一直在与经历带来的创伤作斗争，同时也面临着各种各样的瘾头，比如“瓦查特”（代指各种瘾）。从可卡因到酒精、阿片类药物、社交媒体，然后是色情片和各种各样的事情。所以，你能说出来的，他们都上瘾了。而且，你知道的，他们有一种战士心态。因此，他们中有那么多人感到十分困惑，
many of your patients were soldiers who had seen combat. They had struggled with the trauma of their experiences, but also with a host of addictions, like Wachat. Everything from cocaine to alcohol to opioids to social media and then porn and all sorts of things. So, you name it, they were addicted to it. And, you know, they had this warrior mentality. And so it was baffling to so many of them
他们可以做所有这些其他人甚至连想都不敢想的极其艰难的事情，然而他们却戒不掉烟。你尝试了多种方法来帮助你的病人戒烟。其中许多是你当年在医学院学到的东西的延伸。其中一个涉及控制导致不健康行为（如吸烟）的触发因素或线索。告诉我这种方法，贾德。
that they could do all of these extremely hard things that so many other people could never even think of doing, yet they couldn't quit smoking. You tried a number of approaches to help your patients quit cigarettes. Many of them were extensions of what you had been taught in medical school. One involved controlling the triggers or cues
是的，所以有一句俗话，人、地、物。例如，一个与酒精作斗争的人，如果他们避开酒吧，如果他们避开酒类商店，如果他们避开酒友，他们被触发喝酒的可能性就会小得多。从机制的角度来看，这实际上是有道理的。
that led to unhealthy behaviors like smoking. Tell me about this approach, Judd. Yes, so there's this saying, the people, places, and things. So for example, somebody struggling with alcohol, if they avoid bars, if they avoid the liquor store, if they avoid their drinking buddies, they're much less likely to be triggered to drink. And that actually makes sense from a mechanistic standpoint.
这些触发因素在某种程度上引发了过程。然而，如果你想想吸烟，如果一个人一天抽一包烟，就有20个不同的时间或地点会触发他们吸烟。所以可能是他们的车，可能是工作场所外面，可能是他们的前廊或家里。所以他们基本上必须被扔到
These triggers kind of set off the process. If you think of smoking though, if somebody smokes a pack of cigarettes a day, there are 20 different times or places that they are triggered to smoke. So it could be their car, it could be outside of work, it could be on their front porch or in their house. And so they basically have to be dropped
荒岛上，如果他们想用回避方法的话。所以我们可以看到它在某些情况下会有点帮助，而在另一些情况下，比如吸烟，使用这种方法极其困难。另一种常用的应对渴望的策略涉及分心，将你的注意力从渴望转移到其他事情上。这种技术对你的病人效果如何？嗯，同样，这很有道理。
onto a desert island if they wanted to use the avoidance approach. So we can see it can be somewhat helpful in some situations and in other situations like smoking extremely difficult to use that method. Another commonly used strategy for responding to cravings involved distraction, drawing your attention away from the craving to something else. How did this technique work out for your patients? Well again, it makes a lot of sense.
这非常合乎逻辑，你知道的，分散一下注意力。如果你对香烟有渴望，你知道的，去散散步，或者看一个YouTube视频，或者做点什么来分散你的注意力。问题是它总是挥之不去。你知道的，就像我们和杰姬谈过的那样，它会一直在幕后。这只是它什么时候最终，你知道的，什么时候最终爆发出来的问题。
It's very logical, you know, just distract yourself. If you have a craving for a cigarette, you know, go for a walk or watch a YouTube video or do something that distracts you. The problem is that it's always lingering in the background. You know, kind of like we talked about with Jackie, it's going to be there behind the curtain. It's just a matter of when they eventually, you know, when eventually it gets out.
所有策略中最常见的是通过意志力来抵抗渴望。这种方法的失败率极高，但要求人们用意志力与渴望作斗争总是附带一个内置的逃生条款。当人们屈服于他们的渴望时，你总是可以对他们说，很明显你没有锻炼足够的意志力。如果你做了，你本可以拒绝的。
The most common strategy of all was to resist cravings through willpower. The failure rate of this approach was extremely high, but asking people to fight cravings with willpower always came with a built-in escape clause. When people succumb to their cravings, you could always tell them, clearly you didn't exercise enough willpower. If you did, you could have just said no.
两件事会发生，其中一件非常普遍，以至于现在有一个科学术语叫“戒断违反效应”。这意味着当一个人，他们长期抵制吸烟或抵制喝酒，第一支烟或第一杯酒就会，你知道的，打开闸门，他们就会彻底疯狂。所以有人可以戒烟六个月，突然在三天内又恢复到一天一包。最重要的是，他们会严厉斥责自己。他们会为自己的所作所为感到内疚。他们会作为一个人的身份感到羞耻，内疚和羞耻在某种恶性循环中互相滋养，你知道的，内疚会滋养羞耻，羞耻又会滋养更多行为，
Two things would happen, and one of them is so common that there's now a scientific term for this called the abstinence violation effect. And what that means is that when somebody, they've resisted smoking for a long time or resisted drinking, that first cigarette or that first drink just, you know, opened the flood gates and they would just go nuts. So somebody could quit smoking for six months and suddenly they're back up to a pack a day in three days. And then on top of it, they would castigate themselves. They'd feel guilty for what they did. They'd feel ashamed as a person and the guilt and shame kind of fed on each other as these vicious cycles where, you know where guilt would feed shame, which would feed more behavior,
这反过来又会让他们再次感到内疚。我想知道像这样治疗一个又一个又一个病人是什么感觉。我的意思是，你会经常看到你帮助他们的努力没有奏效吗？是的，几乎每天都是这样。这非常让人谦卑。我觉得我在医学院漏掉了什么东西。
which would then lead them to feel more guilty again. I'm wondering what it was like to treat patient after patient after patient like this. I mean, would you see that on a regular basis that your efforts to help them were not working? Yes, pretty much every day. It was pretty humbling. And I felt like I'd missed something in medical school.
也许我错过了某些非常重要的课程，或者我没有抓住什么。我的病人在苦苦挣扎，而我在帮助他们时也举步维艰。是的，我听说有一个特别的时刻，你被迫认识到你帮助病人抵抗渴望的努力是徒劳的。
Maybe I slept through some class that was really important or I hadn't gotten something. And my patients were really struggling, but I was really struggling to help them. Yeah, I understand that there was one moment in particular where you were forced to recognize the futility of your efforts to help your patients resist their cravings.
你当时正站在退伍军人医院的办公室里。告诉我发生了什么，贾德。是的，这对我来说有点像“电灯泡亮起”的时刻。退伍军人医院是一个无烟园区，所以我的病人在园区里不能抽烟，但他们可以找到没人会真正管制的停车场。所以有一天我看着窗外，看到，你知道的，我的病人在停车场吸烟。我当时有了一个“啊哈”时刻，因为我的实验室多年来一直在研究习惯改变，我在想，等一下，
You were standing in your office at the VA hospital. Tell me what happened, Jett. Yes, this is kind of a light bulb moment for me. So the VA hospital is a smoke-free campus, and so my patients couldn't smoke on campus, but they could find the parking lot where nobody would really police that. And so I was looking out my window one day and seeing, you know, my patients smoking in the parking lot. And I had this aha moment because my lab had been studying habit change for years. And I was thinking, wait a minute,
我的病人在我的办公室里并没有学会抽烟。他们没有在我的办公室里学会暴饮暴食。他们没有在我的办公室里养成任何上瘾行为。有没有什么方法我可以真正开发一种方式，把我的办公室搬到他们身处的情境中去，因为这背后的机制实际上是关于他们在特定语境下学习东西。
my patients don't learn to smoke in my office. They don't learn to overeat in my office. They don't learn to get into any of their addictive behaviors in my office. Is there some way that I could actually develop a way to port my office to them in their situations because the mechanism behind this is really about them learning things in a particular context.
是在他们的家庭环境中，是在他们的车里，是在他们感到压力的时候，而希望他们在我的办公室里并不是特别有压力。所以这是一个很大的“啊哈”时刻，让人觉得，嗯，一定有别的方法来做这件事。但我也能想象，从你的窗户看着这些病人，我的意思是，他们刚刚进来见过你。你给了他们最好的建议，你传达了所有正确的健康信息，而，
It's in their home environment, it's in their car, it's when they're stressed, and hopefully they're not particularly stressed in my office. So that was a big aha for thinking, well, there's got to be a different way to do this. But I can also imagine that looking at these patients from your window, I mean, they've just come in to see you. You've given them the best advice and you've communicated all the right health messages and, you
你知道的，他们走出去，走到停车场，点燃了烟。在某个时刻，如果你是一个看着这个场景的医生，那里必定有一种徒劳感，一种无助感。哦，是的，这极其让人谦卑。我吃了很多苦头。所以你曾在某个时刻，与一组患者一起工作。
know, they step outside and walk to the parking lot and light up. And at some point, if you're a doctor looking at the scene, there has to be a sense of futility, a sense of helplessness there. Oh yes, it's tremendously humbling. I ate a lot of humble pie. So you had a moment at one point where you were working with a group of patients.
这些是饮食有问题的女性。我听说那是一个周四晚上的5点刚过。给我描绘一下当时的场景，这些女性是谁，她们为什么在和你谈话，以及发生了什么。是的，在我的门诊诊所，我们会举办这些集体医疗访问，患有相似病情的人，我可以作为集体同时与他们每个人一起工作。
These were women who had issues with eating. I understand it was just after 5 p.m. on a Thursday evening. Paint me a picture of the scene, who these women were, why they were talking with you, and what happened. Yes, in my outpatient clinic, we would have these group medical visits where people with similar conditions, I could kind of work with them all
所以我聚集了一群人，当时恰好全都是女性，她们真的在与暴食症作斗争，这是一种非常严重的临床疾病，她们基本上在某些情况下就是无法停止吃东西。所以我非常兴奋开始尝试帮助这些人。
at the same time as a group. And so I collected a group of individuals, happened to be all women at the time, who were really struggling with binge eating disorder, very severe clinical disorder where they're, they basically just can't stop eating in certain situations. And so I was really excited to get started, trying to help these people.
大约一个月的时间里，我坐在那里想：我到底漏掉了什么？我觉得我们说的是不同的语言。所以我的语言是，好吧，你知道的，我有一个假设，即人们在饿的时候会吃东西。我对他们的经历实在是一无所知。所以我开始要求他们设身处地为我着想，比如从第一口开始，为我勾勒出细节，是什么促使他们吃东西，他们的渴望是什么样的，他们什么时候吃东西？于是她们开始七嘴八舌地一起说：
And for about a month, I was sitting there thinking like, what am I missing? I felt like we were speaking a different language. So my language was, well, you know, I had this assumption that people would eat when they're hungry. I was really blind to what their experience was. And so I started asking them to put me in their shoes and like starting from the first bite, sketch out the details for me, what urged them to eat, what were their cravings like, when did they eat? So they all started talking at once like,
哦，他终于想要了解我们的世界了。所以这对我来说是又一次令人谦卑的经历。于是她们描述了导致暴食的所有不同时间和触发因素。你知道的，可能是时间，可能是不同的情绪，可能是人。她们在回顾她们的渴望和冲动确实是同样对食物的不懈驱动。其中一个人说：“嗯，我有渴望的时候就会吃。”然后我在想，哦，多告诉我一些这个，你知道的，
oh, finally he wants to understand our world. So another humbling experience for me. And so they were describing all the different times and triggers that led to a binge. You know, it could be time of day, it could be different emotions, it could be people. They were recounting how their cravings and urges really were the same relentless drive to eat. One of the people said, well I just eat when I have a craving and then I was thinking, oh tell me more about this, you know, like
当你饿的时候，渴望是什么样的？所有人都安静了，她们说：“饿？我有一种冲动，然后我就大吃特吃，就是这样。”所以，你知道的，就像生气、孤独、疲惫、无聊、悲伤、分心、兴奋，所有这些东西都有一个共同点，它们引起了渴望。所以那是享乐性饥饿，对吧？不是实际的生理饥饿，对大多数人来说，是情绪上的饥饿在驱动他们
what are the cravings like when you're hungry? Everybody was quiet and they're like, hunger? I have an urge and I eat like full-on, that's it. And so, you know, it's like angry, lonely, tired, bored, sad, distracted, excited, all of these things had one thing in common, they caused a craving. And so it was that hedonic hunger, right? Not actual physiologic hunger, it was the emotional hunger for most of them that was driving them
大多数时候都在吃东西。所以在某种程度上，从医学角度和健康角度来看，你可以理解为什么医生会说，你知道的，我们有经过几万年进化微调的饥饿信号，我们应该只听从那些饥饿信号，这些饥饿信号会告诉我们什么时候该吃，什么时候该停止吃。但当然，这里发生的事情是叠加在数千年进化教会我们何时感到饥饿之上的东西，因为正是我们的情感生活可能在实际上驱动着我们何时选择去拿那块糖果、那支烟或那杯酒。
to eat most of the time. So in some ways from a medical perspective and from a health perspective you can see why you know doctors would say you know we have these hunger signals that have been fine-tuned over many tens of thousands of years of evolution we should just listen to those hunger signals and those hunger signals will tell us when to eat and when to stop eating. But of course, what's happening here is something that's layered on, on top of those thousands of years
绝对的。我会说对于我们许多人来说，大多数时候都是这样。当我们谈论渴望时，我们通常谈论的是我们渴望的东西。
of evolution teaching us when to be hungry, because it's our emotional lives that actually might be driving when we're choosing to reach for that candy or that cigarette or that drink. Absolutely. And I would say for so many of us, this is the case most of the time. When we talk about our cravings, we usually talk about the things we are craving.
香烟、酒精、一大块芝士蛋糕。我们经常不谈论的是我们渴望背后的东西。当我们回来时，贾德决定尝试一种不同的方法来应对我们的渴望。当我们回来时，贾德决定尝试一种不同的方法来应对渴望，无需意志力。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们许多人经常告诉自己要正确饮食，避免不健康的习惯，并且只适度接触诱惑。但在一次又一次地坚持之后，我们往往会屈服于不受控制的放纵。
Cigarettes, alcohol, a gigantic slice of cheesecake. What we often don't talk about are the things that are behind our cravings. When we come back, Judd decides to try a different approach our cravings. When we come back, Jud decides to try a different approach to cravings, no willpower required. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many of us constantly tell ourselves to eat right, to avoid unhealthy habits, and to engage with temptations only in moderation. But after holding out and holding out, we often give in to uncontrolled indulgence.
贾德·布鲁尔的一位患者将她的冲动拟人化为一只“渴望怪兽”。这只怪兽体型巨大且强大，无论她如何努力与它搏斗，它最终通常都会赢。随着时间的推移，贾德·布鲁尔开始发现，这只怪兽背后有一个提线木偶师在操纵它的丝线。在他的著作《渴望的头脑：从香烟到智能手机再到爱情，我们为什么上瘾以及如何打破坏习惯》以及《饥饿的习惯：为什么我们在不饿时进食以及如何停止》中，他问道：如果我们审视站在怪兽身后的那个木偶师，会发生什么？
One of Judd Brewer's patients personified her urges in the form of a craving monster. The monster was huge and powerful and no matter how hard she fought it, it usually won in the end. In time, Judd Brewer came to see that the monster had a puppeteer who was pulling its strings. In his books, the craving mind from cigarettes to smartphones to love, why we get hooked and how we can who was pulling its strings. In his books, The Craving Mind, From Cigarettes to Smartphones to Love, Why We Get Hooked and How We Can Break Bad Habits, and The Hunger Habit, Why We Eat When We're Not Hungry and How to Stop, he asks what would happen if we examined the puppeteer standing behind the monster. Judd, after you had the insight that we lack awareness into why we engage in unhealthy
贾德，在你洞察到我们缺乏对为什么从事不健康行为的认识之后，你在自己身上做了一个小实验。你当时正准备狼吞虎咽地吃下一袋软糖虫。给我描绘一下那天晚上发生了什么。我甚至不记得那天晚上是什么促使我去狂吃软糖虫的，但我就在那儿，而且我一直在学习如何更多地注意我自己的，我自己的感官。所以我开始在我吃软糖虫的时候只是注意它。
behaviors, you ran a little experiment on yourself. You were about to snarf down a bag of gummy worms. Paint me a picture of what happened that night. I don't even remember what prompted me to go on the gummy worm binge that night, but there I was and I'd been kind of learning how to pay attention to my own, my own senses more. So I kind of started just paying attention as I was eating gummy worms. And so instead of just chowing on them in like craving the next one,
所以，不是像渴望下一个那样狼吞虎咽，而是在一个，你知道的，当我嚼着一个的时候，我一次吃一个，并真正注意它们的触感和味道。直到今天我仍然能记住，这已经是多年前的事了，因为它是如此生动，因为它对我来说是一个巨大的震惊。我，我的第一，我的第一反应是：哦，这尝起来像是一种黏糊糊的石油产品。
while one was, you know, while I was chewing on one, I ate one at a time and really paid attention to what they felt like and what they tasted like. And I can still remember to this day, and this was years ago, cause it was so vivid cause it was such a shock to me. I, my first, my first reaction was, Oh, this tastes like a slimy petroleum product.
不太像食物。口感有点不对劲。味道太腻太甜了。它们卡在我的牙缝里。所以这有点烦人。这就像，你其实没法完全咬穿它，但你又可以。所以它，它，就我的大脑和身体进化出对食物的期望而言，所有东西都有点不对劲。
Not exactly food. The mouth feel was slightly off. The taste was too sickly sweet. They were getting stuck in my teeth. So that was kind of annoying. It was like, you can't really bite all the way through it, but you can. And so it was, it was, everything was kind of off in terms of probably what my brain and body had evolved
但我以前从未注意到这一点。我当时正忙着把它们塞进嘴里。当贾德密切注意吃软糖虫的时候，发生了非同寻常的事情。他意识到他其实并不喜欢那种味道。当他吸入整整一袋时，他什么味道也没尝到。但就在他注意到他的感官在告诉他什么的那一刻，
to expect in terms of food. But I had never paid attention to that before. I was just busy shoveling them in my mouth. Something extraordinary happened to Jad as he paid close attention to eating the gummy worms. He realized he didn't really like that taste. When he was inhaling an entire bag, he wasn't tasting anything. But the moment he paid attention to what his senses were telling him,
他意识到自己并不快乐。几乎紧接着有了第二个认识，尽管这与其说是一个推论，不如说是他自己的身体得出的一个结论。他不再想把软糖虫塞满嘴了。贾德回想起他曾试图帮助的患者，他问自己：我这一直都搞错了吗？你知道的，我从我的病人们身上学到了很多。通常他们在失去一切（字面意义上）之前是没有动力改变的。
he realized that he wasn't enjoying himself. A second realization followed almost immediately, although this was less of a deduction and more of a conclusion his own body had reached. He no longer felt like stuffing his mouth with gummy worms. Judd thought back to the patients he had tried to help, and he asked himself, have I been approaching this all wrong? You know, I've learned so much from my patients. Often they're not motivated to change until they've often lost everything, literally.
所以对我作为一名临床医生来说，我在想：你知道，我作为一名临床医生失败了。所以对我作为一名临床医生来说，这是一个触底反弹的时刻。于是我开始，我做了一件疯狂的事，或者在当时看起来很疯狂的事，那就是，我想，好吧，如果标准的方法、意志力的方法对我和我的病人们不管用，让我们尝试完全不同的东西。所以我开始，我的病人们会进来，他们想戒烟，他们以前都尝试过意志力，但不管用。所以我说，好吧，继续抽烟吧。
And so for me as a clinician, I'm thinking, you know, I am failing as a clinician. So it was a rock bottom moment for me as a clinician. And so I started, I did this crazy thing, which was, or seemed crazy at the time, which was, I thought, well, okay, if the standard approaches, the willpower approaches aren't working for me and my patients, let's try something completely different. And so I started, my patients would come in, they wanted to quit smoking, they'd all tried willpower before, it hadn't worked. And so I said, okay, go ahead and smoke.
他们看着我的眼神就像看疯子一样。他们说：我没听错吧？我的医生刚刚叫我抽烟？对吧？他们都知道吸烟对他们是最糟糕的事情之一。所以我不需要在一个讲台上重复这一点，但我可以说：嘿，你知道的，嗯，当你抽烟时，
And they would look at me like I was crazy. And they're like, did I hear you right? My doctor just told me to smoke, right? And they all know that smoking is one of the worst things for them. So I don't need to reiterate that at some lecture on a, you know, from a podium, but I can say, hey, you know, well, when you smoke,
因为你反正会抽的，对吧？你停不下来。所以抽烟的时候注意观察。我会给他们布置家庭作业。我会说：向我汇报你抽烟时的具体感受。那么它尝起来是什么味道？烟雾进入肺部是什么感觉？
cause you're going to do it anyway, right? You can't stop. So just pay attention as you smoke. And I would give them a homework assignment. I would say, report back to me exactly what it's like when you smoke. So what does it taste like? What does the smoke feel like going into your lungs?
从你的嘴巴或鼻子出来是什么气味？你的衣服是什么气味？你知道的，你的口气是什么气味和味道？所有这些。所以我让他们做了一个科学实验，他们既是实验对象，又是实验人员，
What does it smell like coming out of your mouth or your nose? What do your clothes smell like? You know, what is your breath smell and taste like? All of that. So I had them do a science experiment, and they were the experiment, and they were the experimenter,
然后他们回来时被震撼了。在某种程度上，这与你决定在真正吃软糖虫时注意观察时发生的情况如出一辙。你对这件东西的体验完全改变了。是的，我真的很好奇。研究界经常开玩笑说，研究就是“自我研究”（mesearch），
and they would come back blown away. And in some ways, this is along the lines of what happened when you decided to pay attention when you were actually eating the gummy worms. Your experience of the thing completely was transformed. Yes, I was really curious. Often the joke in research is research is me search
人们经常陷入这样的死胡同，他们会想：哦，某种方法对我有用，所以它一定对每个人都有用。而这些通常是非常聪明、非常有纪律的科学家或心理学家。所以他们就会去开发一种治疗方法。他们会想：嗯，这对我管用，它应该对其他人也管用。
and often people go down these rabbit holes where they're like, oh, something worked for me and so it must work for everyone. And often these are very smart, very disciplined scientists or psychologists. And so then they go and develop a treatment. They're like, well, it worked for me. It should work for everyone else.
如果它不是真正基于某种机制，它可能对其他人不管用。所以对我来说，我当时想，嗯，让我们来看看这东西是如何运作的，并做一些随机对照试验来看看它是否真的管用。但首先，我有很多患者足够慷慨，愿意自己尝试一下。所以我可以做一些试点工作，看看是否真的有信号。但首先，你知道的，我有很多患者足够慷慨，愿意自己尝试一下。所以我可以做一些试点工作，看看那里甚至是否有信号。
And it may not work for everyone else if it's not really based on a mechanism. And so for me, I was like, well, let's look at this to see how this works and do some randomized controlled trials to see if it actually works. But first, I had a lot of patients who were generous enough to kind of try this out themselves. So I could just do some pilot trials to see if it actually works. But first, you know, I had a lot of patients who were generous enough to kind of try this out themselves. So I could just do some pilot work to see if there was even a signal there.
每次我这样做，我依然很喜欢它。因为我迫不及待地想听到我的病人的反馈。所以，你知道的，通常我记得有一个家伙抽了40年烟。所以我们做的第一件事是计算他强化这个习惯的次数。他对此做好了准备。大约是他强化这个习惯足足293,000次。
And every time I do this, I still love it. Cause I can't wait to hear back from my patients. So, you know, typically I remember a guy had been smoking for 40 years. And so the first thing we did was calculate the number of times he had reinforced this habit. He was ready for this. It was roughly 293,000 times that he had kind of reinforced this habit.
所以，然后我说：开始注意。他回来了，他说：我怎么会没有注意到这一点？你知道的，他抽了40年烟。他说：这些东西尝起来就像垃圾。我怎么会不知道这一点？他被震撼了。我从来没有一个病人回来感谢我帮他们意识到香烟的味道有多么美味。
So, and so I said, start paying attention. He comes back and he goes, how did I not notice this? You know, for 40 years he'd been smoking. He's like, these things taste like crap. How did I not know this? He was blown away. I've never had a patient come back and thank me for helping them realize how delicious cigarettes taste.
从来没有。所以当你要求人们去练习好奇心时，你也要求他们练习一种你称之为“慈悲的好奇心”的东西。有什么区别呢，贾德？是的，嗯，我认为善良和好奇心是最好的朋友。所以通常要真正做到好奇，这意味着我们不会带着
Never. So when you ask people to exercise curiosity, you also ask them to exercise something that you call kind curiosity. What is the difference, Judd? Yes, well, I think of kindness and curiosity being best friends. So often to truly be curious, which means we're not going in
从不。所以，当你要求人们去实践好奇心时，你也要求他们去实践一种你称之为“善意的好奇心”的东西。贾德，这两者有什么区别？是的，嗯，我认为善良和好奇心是最好的朋友。通常，要真正做到好奇，这意味着我们不会带着……
with a preconceived notion or a judgment. We're just going in like, oh, let's see what this actually is. So in Zen, they often talk about beginner's mind or don't know mind, right? And it's like, oh, I don't really know. Let's explore this. let's see what this actually is. So in Zen, they often talk about beginner's mind or don't know mind, right? It's like, oh, I don't really know, let's explore this. Well, often we have these voices in our heads
带着先入为主的想法或判断。我们只是抱着“哦，让我们看看这到底是什么”的心态。所以在禅宗里，他们经常谈论初心或不知心，对吧？就像是，“哦，我其实并不了解。让我们探索一下，让我们看看这到底是什么。”所以在禅宗里，他们经常谈论初心或不知心，对吧？就像是，“哦，我其实并不了解，让我们探索一下。”嗯，通常我们脑海里会有这些声音
that are like judging everything and that judgemental voice kind of gets in the way of us seeing clearly. And one thing that our brains so often do is get in this habit loop of judging ourselves and shaming and blaming and all of these things that just suck all of this energy away from us being able to be curious in a situation and also get us stuck fighting ourselves
它们就像是在评判一切，而这种评判性的声音某种程度上会妨碍我们看清真相。我们的大脑经常做的一件事，就是陷入这种自我评判、羞愧、责怪以及所有这些事情的习惯循环中，这些事情把我们能够在一个情境中保持好奇心的所有能量都吸干了，并且让我们陷入与自己的斗争中
instead of actually addressing the issue. So if somebody can be kind to themselves, they can help step back from the self-judgmental stories and truly explore what's happening in their experience without that judgmental lens. And there's a metaphor here that multiple people have used of thinking about a parent who is dealing with a child who is very upset,
而不是真正去解决问题。所以，如果一个人能够对自己仁慈，他们就能帮助自己从那些自我评判的故事中抽离出来，在没有这种评判视角的情况下，真正去探索他们的经历中正在发生什么。这里有一个隐喻，许多人都用过，那就是把一个正在应付一个非常沮丧的孩子的父母
maybe a small child who's having a tantrum, for example. And of course, the parent could get swept up in the tantrum as well and get excited and upset and angry or fearful. But really, what you're really called upon to do if you're a parent is actually to not get into the tantrum with your toddler. You actually have to stand outside of the tantrum,
比方说，一个正在发脾气的幼儿。当然，父母也可能会被卷入这场脾气中，变得激动、心烦意乱、生气或恐惧。但实际上，如果你是一位父母，你真正需要做的是不要和你的幼儿一起发脾气。你实际上必须置身于这场脾气之外，
but not ignore the tantrum altogether. Not just sort of say, I don't care what's happening to the kid, but who actually say, I'm curious about what's happening to you, but I'm not so wrapped up or so consumed with what's happening to you that I'm in the maelstrom with you.
但又不是完全忽视这场脾气。不是那种说“我不在乎这孩子怎么了”的态度，而是真正去说：“我对你身上发生的事情很好奇，但我并没有被你身上发生的事情彻底吞没或卷入其中，以至于我和你一起陷入了狂风巨浪之中。”
Yes, I love this metaphor. We even use it in our digital therapeutic programs. This highlights several things. One is if the parent gets wrapped up in the story, it becomes about them and not about their child. So if they ignore their child, it's about them. If it's fighting, it's like kind of resisting their child's tantrum, it's about them.
是的，我很喜欢这个隐喻。我们甚至在我们的数字治疗项目中使用它。这突出了几件事。第一，如果父母卷入了故事中，事情就变成了关于他们自己，而不是关于他们的孩子。所以，如果他们忽视孩子，这是关于他们自己的。如果是争吵，这有点像是抗拒孩子的脾气，这也是关于他们自己的。
Instead, we can get curious and ask a very different question that's gonna actually solve the problem and also take care of the child. So it's really about being able to step back and instead of going, oh no, they're screaming again, I need to get them to be quiet as quickly as possible, they can go, oh, what do they need?
相反，我们可以保持好奇，并问一个完全不同的问题，这个问题实际上既能解决问题又能照顾到孩子。所以这实际上是关于能够退一步，而不是去想：“哦不，他又在尖叫了，我需要尽快让他安静下来”，他们可以去想：“哦，他需要什么？”
And that brings in kindness, it brings in curiosity and turns it toward the question that is critical that needs to be answered then. It's like, what does my child actually need? And the analogy here with our own emotions and cravings is that if we think about our emotions and cravings like that crying toddler, instead of battling the child, instead of battling our cravings, the idea is by being curious about them, we in some ways can quiet them down Yes, and this is a paradox. So I think of it this way, you know, we're so trained to do something Oh, no, they're screaming. Oh, no, there's a craving. Oh, no, there's this I need to do something about it to make it go away
这就带来了仁慈、好奇心，并将其转向当时需要回答的关键问题。就像：“我的孩子到底需要什么？”这里与我们自己的情绪和渴望的类比是，如果我们把情绪和渴望想象成那个哭闹的幼儿，不去对抗这个孩子，不去对抗我们的渴望，我们的想法是通过对它们保持好奇，在某种程度上我们可以让它们安静下来。是的，这是一个悖论。所以我是这样想的，你知道，我们受过太多的训练去做点什么：“哦不，他们在尖叫。哦不，有渴望了。哦不，是这个。我需要做点什么来让它消失。”
Well the doing something about it is just like what Jackie was doing with the craving monster We either run away it runs after us or we fight with it and it gets stronger. So here the paradox is that if we can learn to be with our experience, that curiosity helps us lean in and just explore, oh, what is this experience? And that being with our experience becomes the new doing. We learned that these are thoughts, these are sensations, these are emotions that come and go. And by opening ourselves to them,
嗯，所谓的“做点什么”就像杰基对渴望怪兽做的事情一样：要么我们逃跑，要么它追着我们跑，要么我们与它抗争，结果它变得更强大了。所以这里的悖论是，如果我们能学会与我们的体验共存，这种好奇心就会帮助我们倾身向前，去探索：“哦，这种体验是什么？”而这种与我们的体验共存就成了新的“做”。我们了解到这些是想法，这些是感觉，这些是来来去去的 emozioni（情感）。通过向它们敞开心扉，
allowing them to manifest in all their colors and energies and timeframes, that they will go away on their own without us doing anything. And the less we feed them, the less they come back. So you've tried to operationalize this fundamental insight in a three-step process for dealing with our cravings. And the first of these is to apply kind curiosity
允许它们以所有的色彩、能量和时间框架显现出来，它们就会自行消失，而不需要我们做任何事情。我们喂养它们的越少，它们回来的次数就越少。所以你试图将这个核心洞察操作化为一个三步流程，用来应对我们的渴望。其中的第一步是将温和的好奇心
to the situations in which our cravings arise. What does this look like, Judd? Well, I'll give you, maybe we can start with a story that kind of highlights this. And I remember this patient coming into my office and the first thing he says is, hey doc, my head's going to explode if I don't smoke. And I'm thinking, oh crap,
应用到我们渴望出现的情境中。这看起来是怎样的，贾德？嗯，我给你讲讲，也许我们可以从一个突显这一点的故事开始。我记得有个病人来到我的办公室，他说的第一句话是：“嘿，医生，如果我不抽烟，我的头就要爆炸了。”我想：“糟糕，
I didn't learn this one in medical school, chief complaint, head exploding from craving. And so I had to improvise. And of course, my habit is to go to a whiteboard as a researcher and as a teacher. So I'm trying to buy time. So I fumble out a marker, a dry erase marker, and I say, okay, describe what head exploding feels like
我在医学院可没学过这个，主诉：因渴望导致头部爆炸。”所以我不得不即兴发挥。当然，作为一名研究人员和老师，我的习惯是走到白板前。所以我在试图争取时间。我笨手笨脚地拿出一支马克笔，一支干擦马克笔，然后说：“好吧，描述一下头部爆炸是什么感觉，
and how intense it is. And so he was describing, you know, heat and burning and tightness and tension. And then he was describing that the intensity was going up and up and up and up. And so I was drawing this arrow and trying to capture some of the words along the way. And then at some point, the intensity peaked
以及它有多强烈。”于是他描述了热感、灼烧感、紧绷感和张力。然后他描述说，强度越来越高、越来越高、越来越高。于是我画了这条箭头，并试图沿途捕捉一些字眼。然后在某个时候，强度达到了顶峰，
and started to go back down. And he stopped at that moment. And I said, what's going on? And he said, you know, I've always smoked before the craving got this intense. But here it went down and I didn't smoke a cigarette. And it was this big aha moment for him where he realized that these cravings
开始回落。他在那一刻停了下来。我问：“怎么了？”他说：“你知道，以前在渴望变得这么强烈之前我总是抽烟。但在这里，它降下去了，我没有抽烟。”对他来说，这是一个巨大的“啊哈”时刻，他意识到这些渴望
were made up of thoughts and sensations, emotions, and that just by naming them, and even naming them out loud, it helped them see them for what they were. And in psychology, they describe this as the observer effect. By observing our thoughts, we cannot simultaneously be identified with them. And so this patient was observing his thoughts and body sensations instead of being consumed by them and identified with them. By doing that, he realized that he was not his thoughts,
是由思想、感觉和情绪构成的，仅仅通过给它们命名，甚至大声说出它们的名字，就能帮助他看清它们的真面目。在心理学中，他们将这描述为“观察者效应”。通过观察我们的想法，我们不可能同时认同它们。所以这个病人是在观察他的想法和身体感觉，而不是被它们吞没并认同它们。通过这样做，他意识到他不是他的想法，
he was not his body sensations, and that he had control by simply observing them. He could be with his body sensations rather than having to do something like resist a craving or smoke a cigarette. You had another patient whom you call Rob Judd, and you asked Rob why it was that he would compulsively overeat. And you asked him to pay very close attention
他不是他的身体感觉，并且通过简单地观察它们，他就拥有了控制权。他可以与自己的身体感觉共存，而不必去做诸如抗拒渴望或抽烟之类的事情。你还有另一个病人，你叫他罗布，贾德，你问罗布为什么他会强迫性地暴饮暴食。你让他密切关注
to his eating as he was compulsively overeating. What did he tell you? It's interesting. Rob first came to me for anxiety. He had panic disorder. He had generalized anxiety disorder for probably 30 years when he came to see me. And he, oh, and I should also mention he was 400 pounds.
他在强迫性进食时的饮食过程。他对你说了什么？这很有趣。罗布最初是因为焦虑来找我的。他有恐慌症。当他来找我时，他可能已经有30年的广泛性焦虑障碍了。而且他，哦，我還应该提到他有400磅重。
He had clinically relevant obesity in the sense that he had obstructive sleep apnea affecting a lot of his body systems. He had hypertension, high blood pressure. He had basically a fatty liver, all of these related to his unhealthy weight. And so what he described to me was that as a kid, he started eating, so he had anxiety,
他患有临床意义上的肥胖症，表现为阻塞性睡眠呼吸暂停，影响了他身体的许多系统。他有高血压。他基本上有脂肪肝，所有这些都与他不健康的体重有关。所以他向我描述的是，作为一个孩子，他开始吃东西是因为他有焦虑，
probably starting fifth grade or something like that, where he tried everything he could to help his panic and his anxiety. And the only thing at the time that seemed to help was him going home and eating a bunch of food. And for him, especially by the time he came to see me, it wasn't even a temptation, it was a drug. And he described fast food as his addiction.
大概从五年级左右开始，他尝试了一切可能的方法来帮助缓解他的恐慌和焦虑。而当时唯一似乎有用的方法就是回家吃大量的食物。对她来说，尤其是当他来找我的时候，这甚至不是一种诱惑，而是一种毒品。他将快餐描述为他的瘾。
He would secretly eat fast food in his car and throw out all the garbage to hide his behavior from everyone else. And then he would tell himself, just like I've had so many other people with addictions say, I'll be better tomorrow. I'm gonna start tomorrow. So when you asked him to do the same thing that you asked John to do, to pay very close attention
他会偷偷在车里吃快餐，然后扔掉所有的垃圾，以对其他人隐瞒他的行为。然后他会告诉自己，就像我遇到的许多其他有瘾的人说的那样：“我明天会好起来的。我从明天开始。”所以当你要求他做你让约翰做的事——密切关注
to what it felt like to indulge in the craving, what was his experience like, Chad? When he started paying attention as he ate, he realized that the fast food was actually giving him more health anxiety because he knew that he needed to lose weight because of all these clinical conditions. And so he started to realize, you know, eating was actually making things worse. The fast food wasn't helping.
沉溺于渴望时的感觉——他的体验是怎样的，贾德？当他开始在吃东西时注意时，他意识到快餐实际上给他带来了更多的健康焦虑，因为他知道由于所有这些临床状况，他需要减肥。所以他开始意识到，你知道，吃东西实际上让事情变得更糟了。快餐并没有帮忙。
And no kidding, between the first visit and his first follow-up visit, two weeks later, the first thing he says to me is, Hey doc, I lost 14 pounds. And I was stunned because we hadn't even really focused on his clinical obesity issue at that time. We were mainly just in this first visit focusing on anxiety, but he had started to realize he was starting to understand how his mind worked and he was starting to leverage his brain to help him change his eating habits without any willpower.
说真的，在第一次访问和两周后的第一次复诊之间，他对我说的第一句话是：“嘿，医生，我瘦了14磅。”我惊呆了，因为当时我们甚至没有真正关注他的临床肥胖问题。我们主要在第一次访问中关注焦虑，但他已经开始意识到，他开始理解他的大脑是如何运作的，并且他开始利用他的大脑来帮助他在没有任何意志力的情况下改变他的饮食习惯。
So what you're saying Judd is that many of our cravings involve behavior that is automatic and unthinking, but when we apply curiosity to our cravings, in some ways it allows us to take apart the sequence of the emotions that lead to the cravings and the cravings that lead to our behaviors. Absolutely. So I think of this first step of the three-step process is just mapping out your habit loops. And it can be as simple as just identifying the behavior. So like my patients in the binge-eating group, I had them start just recognizing, why is it that I'm reaching for food?
所以你的意思是，贾德，我们的许多渴望都涉及自动化且不经思考的行为，但当我们对渴望保持好奇时，它在某种程度上使我们能够剖析导致渴望的情绪序列，以及导致我们行为的渴望。绝对是这样。所以我觉得三步流程的第一步就是画出你的习惯循环。它就像识别行为一样简单。比如我暴食症小组的病人，我让他们开始只去识别：“我为什么要伸手去拿食物？
Am I hungry or am I X, Y, or Z? Lonely, bored, angry, frustrated, sleepy, whatever. And so just recognizing the eating habit is the first step. So you've evaluated smokers who have participated in your mindfulness program and you found that the urge to smoke and the act of smoking have become uncoupled. Tell me about that research. Yes, we did our first randomized controlled trial. We published this back in 2011.
我是饿了，还是因为X、Y、Z？孤独、无聊、生气、沮丧、困倦，诸如此类。”所以，仅仅识别饮食习惯就是第一步。所以你评估了参加你的正念项目的吸烟者，你发现吸烟的冲动和吸烟的行为已经脱钩了。跟我讲讲那项研究。是的，我们做了我们的第一个随机对照试验。我们在2011年发表了这篇论文。
So we had people, randomized people to get cognitive therapy and you know gold standard. This is the American loan association's freedom from smoking versus this mindfulness training that we had developed. And the mindfulness training was pretty much, you know, like, hey, let's help you explore these cravings, just like you and I've been talking about, you know, what is a craving, but they can also learn to write out cravings, just like I did with my patient whose head did not explode when we explored what head exploding could feel like. And what we found, first off, we found that we got five times the quit rates of gold standard treatment, which totally knocked
所以我们让人群随机接受认知疗法，你知道的，黄金标准。这是美国肺脏协会的“戒烟自由”项目，对比我们开发的这种正念训练。正念训练基本上就是，你知道，嘿，让我们帮你探索这些渴望，就像你和我一直在讨论的那样，你知道，什么是渴望，但他们也可以学会度过渴望，就像我对待那个病人的头一样——当我们探索头部爆炸可能是什么感觉时，他的头并没有爆炸。而我们发现，首先，我们发现戒烟成功率是黄金标准治疗的五倍，这彻底把我
my socks off. We were just looking for a signal. Well, that was a signal. That was pretty striking. So in some ways, the first step of this approach is to make people aware of what the cravings are about, where they're coming from, what's driving them. But the next stage is to actually get people to think very closely about what happens when they're actually consuming the thing that they're craving. And you did this with gummy bears. And this is what you do when you tell smokers to go ahead and smoke, but to pay very close they're craving. And you did this with gummy bears, and this is what you do when you tell smokers to go ahead and smoke, but to pay very close attention to it.
惊艳到了。我们当时只是在寻找一个信号。嗯，那是一个信号。这相当引人注目。所以在某种程度上，这种方法的第一步是让人们意识到渴望是关于什么的、它们来自哪里、是什么在驱动它们。但下一个阶段是真正让人们仔细思考当他们真正消费他们渴望的东西时会发生什么。你是用小熊软糖做到这一点的。这就是你告诉吸烟者继续抽烟，但要密切关注他们渴望的东西时所做的。你用小熊软糖做过这个，这也是你告诉吸烟者继续抽烟，但要密切关注它时所做的事情。
And again, the idea is that paying very close attention to the eating of the food, to the smoking of the cigarette, to the drinking of the wine, it changes your experience of the thing that you were craving. Absolutely. So when we start looking at the core mechanism
同样，这个想法是，密切关注吃食物的行为、抽烟的行为、喝酒的行为，会改变你对你所渴望的东西的体验。绝对的。所以当我们开始审视核心机制
and start asking, how can we leverage the strength of the brain, the way that works is that our brain is going to keep doing things that are rewarding, and it's going to stop doing things that are not rewarding. And the only variable that's needed for that is awareness. And this goes back to the 1970s, these two researchers, Rosquela and Wagner came up with these reinforcement learning models, And this goes back to the 1970s, these two researchers, Roscorla and Wagner came up with these
并开始询问：“我们如何利用大脑的力量？”其运作方式是，我们的大脑会继续做那些有回报的事情，并停止做那些没有回报的事情。而为此所需的唯一变量就是觉察。这可以追溯到20世纪70年代，这两位研究人员，罗斯科拉和瓦格纳，提出了这些强化学习模型，这可以追溯到20世纪70年代，这两位研究人员，罗斯科拉和瓦格纳提出了这些
reinforcement learning models. And they're still at play today. We use these in our studies, where basically if you pay attention, you're gonna get an error term, meaning I learn, hey, these are not as good as expected, and I become disenchanted with that behavior. So it could be a type of food,
强化学习模型。它们今天仍然在起作用。我们在研究中使用了这些模型，基本上，如果你保持注意力，你就会得到一个误差项，这意味着我了解到：“嘿，这些并不像预期那么好”，我对这种行为感到幻灭。所以它可以是一种食物，
it could be an amount of food, it could be cigarettes, and food, it could be an amount of food, it could be cigarettes, and it takes only 10 to 15 times of somebody really paying attention when they do a behavior, if it's not rewarding, for that reward value to drop below zero. So that's the second step in this process.
它可以是一定数量的食物，它可以是香烟，食物，它可以是一定数量的食物，可以是香烟，一个人在做出某种行为时，如果它没有回报，只需真正集中注意力10到15次，该回报价值就会降至零以下。所以这是这个过程的第二步。
We call this developing disenchantment. It doesn't change the taste of food, especially when we are eating in amounts that are not overindulging, but it can actually help us much more easily stop when we're full. The third step in Judd's process to address cravings is that the more you pay attention to your sensations, the more likely it is you will discover what he calls bigger and better alternatives to the things you crave.
我们称之为“培养幻灭感”。它不会改变食物的味道，特别是当我们吃的量没有过度放纵时，但它实际上可以帮助我们在饱腹时更容易地停下来。贾德应对渴望流程的第三步是，你越是关注自己的感觉，你就越有可能发现他所说的“更大更好的替代品”，来替代你渴望的东西。
That's what happened to Judd. Gummy worms have been replaced in his life by something better. I'm smiling just thinking about them. I had some this morning. They are blueberries. So for me, blueberries are the biggest, bestest offer in terms of like a sweet treat. They pop in your mouth.
这就是贾德身上发生的事情。他生活中的软糖虫已经被更好的东西取代了。我一想到它们就在微笑。我今天早上还吃了一些。它们是蓝莓。对我来说，蓝莓是甜食中最好、最棒的选择。它们会在你口中爆开。
They've got this, you know, a nice texture when you bite into them. They also have this intermittent reinforcement property. So you never know how sweet a blueberry is going to be, right? One might be slightly sweeter than another, another might be a little more tart. I like them both, but they kind of keep you constantly surprised when you're eating them. And the nice thing about blueberries is, for me,
当你咬下去时，它们有一种很好的质感。它们还具有间歇性强化的属性。所以你永远不知道一颗蓝莓会有多甜，对吧？一颗可能比另一颗稍微甜一点，另一颗可能更酸一点。两我都喜欢，但当你吃它们时，它们会让你不断感到惊喜。而蓝莓的好处在于，对我来说，
they have this perfect amount of sweetness where I'm not craving the next one or the next pint. We actually, and this is true, we have some gummy things in our house right now that my wife's family member gave to us and I'm not even interested. She doesn't even ask me anymore. Yeah, do you want some? She knows the answer.
它们具有完美的甜度，让我不会渴望下一颗或下一品脱。实际上，千真万确，我们家里现在有一些软糖，是我妻子家里的亲戚给我们的，我甚至都不感兴趣。她甚至不再问我了。“嘿，你想吃点吗？”她知道答案。
So let's return to the story of Jackie, your patient who wrestled for years with what she called the craving monster. She found that curiosity and kindness really did transform her eating habits. Tell me her story, Judd. Yes. So Jackie had a complicated relationship with her mom
那么让我们回到杰基的故事，你的病人，她多年来一直在与她所谓的“渴望怪兽”搏斗。她发现好奇心和仁慈确实改变了她的饮食习惯。跟我讲讲她的故事吧，贾德。好的。所以杰基和她妈妈的关系很复杂，
and had learned some of these eating rules from her mom, in fact. And she had just come from visiting her mom, as she described it, yet another horrible trip. The two hadn't connected. And so she used to be in the habit of going to a certain grocery store and sitting in the parking lot, listening to loud music and just binging and binging. So she sat in her car and she said, it didn't make the upset go away. I still felt really upset and hurt with relation to her interaction with her mom. She said I just bawled my eyes out in the car Here's where it gets really interesting
事实上，她从她妈妈那里学到了一些饮食规则。正如她所描述的，她刚去看望了她妈妈，又是一次糟糕的旅行。两人没有建立起联系。所以她以前习惯于去某家杂货店，坐在停车场里，听着大声的音乐，然后不停地暴饮暴食。所以她坐在车里说：“这并没有让心烦意乱消失。对于与妈妈的互动，我仍然感到非常难过和受伤。”她说她在车里痛哭流涕。接下来事情变得非常有趣了，
She said she allowed the craving monster to get in the car with her instead of ignoring it or resisting it or fighting with it so she simply So she simply noticed what the craving for Chinese food felt like. She could already taste that magic combination of sweet and salty. And she investigated how it felt, how that craving felt in her body, asking exactly what she was feeling and noting the sensations. And then she had this moment of revelation. She put it, I went into the grocery store and each time I picked something up, I asked myself, how am I going to feel if I eat this?
她说她允许渴望怪兽和她一起坐在车里，而不是忽视它、抗拒它或与它搏斗，所以她只是简单地——
And she gave herself permission to binge if she wanted to. And here's what she walked out of the store with, some avocados and spinach. So, and she said, she was laughing like a lunatic as she drove out of the parking lot because it was her first taste of freedom as an adult And she said I don't have to be scared of the craving the craving monster is so real for so many people But she said I see you. Yeah, you can't hurt me
所以她只是注意到对中餐的渴望是什么感觉。她已经能品尝到那种甜咸交织的神奇组合。她调查了这种感觉，这种渴望在她的身体里是什么感觉，确切地询问自己的感受并注意这些感觉。然后她有了顿悟的时刻。她这样说：“我走进杂货店，每当我拿起一样东西，我都问自己：‘如果我吃了这个，我会有什么感觉？’”并且她允许自己在想暴饮暴食时就暴饮暴食。这就是她从店里走出来时拿的东西：一些牛油果和菠菜。所以，她说她开车离开停车场时笑得像个疯子，因为那是她成年后第一次尝到自由的滋味。她说：“我不必害怕渴望了，渴望怪兽对很多人来说是那么真实，但她说：‘我看到你了。是的，你伤害不了我。’
You can't hurt me. There was a lot of fear with her with regard to the craving monster. And she said the fear wasn't there anymore. ["The Hunger Habit," by Justin Brewer, playing in background.] Justin Brewer works at the School of Public Health and Psychiatry in the medical school at Brown University. He's the author of The Hunger Habit, Why We Eat When We're Not Hungry and How to Stop, and The Craving Mind, From Cigarettes to Smartphones to Love, Why We Get Hooked and How We Can
你伤害不了我。”她对渴望怪兽有很多恐惧。她说恐惧不再存在了。[背景音乐响起：《饥饿习惯》，作者：贾斯汀·布鲁尔] 贾斯汀·布鲁尔在布朗大学医学院的公共卫生和精神病学系工作。他是《饥饿习惯：为什么我们在不饿时进食以及如何停止》和《渴望的心灵：从香烟到智能手机再到爱情，我们为什么上瘾以及如何打破坏习惯》一书的作者。
Break Bad Habits. Judd, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. Thanks for having me. Do you have follow-up questions for Judd Brewer about cravings and how to break them? If you'd be willing to share your question with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty.
贾德，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。不客气。谢谢邀请我。你对贾德·布鲁尔关于渴望以及如何打破渴望有什么后续问题吗？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的问题，请在你的手机上录制一条语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。
That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Please use the subject line, Cravings. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy the show and would like to support our work, please consider becoming a member
再重复一遍那个电子邮件地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：Cravings（渴望）。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。如果你喜欢这个节目并想支持我们的工作，请考虑成为我们
of our podcast subscription. Hidden Brain Plus is where you'll find exclusive episodes you won't hear anywhere else. To become a member of Hidden Brain Plus, find Hidden Brain in the Apple Podcasts app and then click the try free button for a 7-day trial. Or you can sign up at apple.co. slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客订阅的会员。“隐藏的大脑Plus”是你寻找其他任何地方都听不到的独家剧集的地方。要成为“隐藏的大脑Plus”会员，请在Apple Podcasts应用程序中找到“隐藏的大脑”，然后点击“免费试用”按钮进行7天试用。或者你可以在 apple.co/hiddenbrain 注册。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。